despite being a company which prides
itself on making kids movies Disney is
responsible for some of the most
disturbing death scenes in cinema
history from tragic family lost to
straight-up body horror these are the
Disney deaths that traumatized us as
children considering so many Disney
characters tend to be orphans the lion
Kings Simba could be counted as lucky
this little lion cub has got a loving
mom and his father Mufasa is protective
gentle and understanding until he gets
trampled to death that is in the film's
darkest moments Simba finds himself
trapped in a gorge desperately trying to
outrun a herd of stampeding wildebeest
just when it looks like he's gonna wind
up as a pride land pancake Mufasa comes
to the rescue
leaping into the Horde of hooves and
horns to save his kid
but while Mufasa gets Simba to safety
climbing out of the gorge proves to be
too difficult for the mighty king
fortunately his dear old brother Skaar
is there to help while the film makes
clear that Mufasa has never been on
great terms with his brother there's
still a look of genuine betrayal on his
face when scar tosses him down to his
doom but the real heartache comes when
Simba tries to get his dad to wake up
nuzzling his lifeless body before
finally relenting and heading into exile
back in 1994 between the 1967 animated
classic and the 2016 remake Disney
released a live action version of the
jungle book the plot of the film has
Mowgli forced to lead a band of British
soldiers to a stash of hidden treasure
but as Mowgli and his sadistic captors
heading to the jungle this PG Kids flick
slowly transforms into a genuine horror
movie one villain falls from a cliff
another is mauled by a tiger while the
big bad eventually ends up in a watery
grave before being finished off by a
gigantic Python at one point a British
bully falls into a pit of quicksand and
despite his friends best efforts slowly
sinks into the muck crying in terror all
the way down another bat he finds
himself caught in a temple trap left
helpless as the roof seals shut and the
room fills with sand and to mean him for
all eternity
not exactly the bare necessities is it
despite the occasional moment of levity
the Hunchback of Notre Dom isn't afraid
to get dark with that said it should
come as no surprise that when the
villainous Claude Frollo meets his end
it comes in the most disturbing way
possible in the film's big finale
brolo is chasing the Hunchback Quasimodo
and his love Esmeralda through the halls
of Notre Dom hoping to catch and kill
the object of his desire the chase
eventually leads to the cathedrals
balcony and after a brief showdown this
happens
even kids can probably understand the
hellish metaphor and display here and
while Frollo does deserve his fate
watching him falling to the flames is
still enough to make anyone fear for
their immortal soul
the folks at Disney know there's nothing
scarier for a kid than the idea that
their mom could die that's one of the
reasons why Bambi is basically the
saddest animated movie ever made and
over 60 years later Pixar followed in
Bambi's hoof prints by traumatizing a
whole new generation with Finding Nemo
the movie opens on a hopeful note with
expectant parents Marlin and coral
moving into their oceanfront and nemenyi
home the two clownfish have over 400
little eggs waiting to hatch and they
couldn't be more excited about their
future that's when Marlin notices in
approaching Barracuda staring straight
at the parents and their unhatched kids
when the Barracuda moves in for the kill
Marlin does his best to ward off the
Beast but is knocked unconscious when he
wakes up coral is gone and every egg
save one has been devoured although we
don't actually see anyone get eaten we
do see poor Marlin mourn his dead wife
and unborn children his heartbreaking
sobs coupled with the idea you really
could lose your mom at any moments would
have made so many kids feel completely
adrift while watching the movie Davy
Jones is arguably one of the great
Disney villains thanks in large part to
a CGI face that still looks amazing
years after his appearance in the
Pirates of the Caribbean sequels with
his lobster hand tentacle chin and
supernatural crew Jones was a force to
be reckoned with
until the East India Trading Company got
a hold of his heart stashed away in a
wooden chest the heart gives the
villainous Cutler Beckett and his
henchman Ian Mercer the ability to
control the pirate lord near the end of
Pirates of the Caribbean at World's End
however Mercer finds out why you should
never play with a Buccaneers heart
during the film's climactic sea battle a
cannonball kills Mercer's men leaving
him alone with the octopus pirate
seizing the chance to reclaim his hearts
Jones kills Mercer in the slimy estroux
tzimmes way possible
it honestly might be the most gruesome
death in any Disney film ever
[Music]